welcome to the future of farming in
today's video we'll explore the best
sustainable Farming tools and
eco-friendly agricultural equipment that
are helping Farmers Embrace A Greener
Future Let's dive into the world of
green farming technologies that protect
the environment while boosting
productivity more than ever farmers are
turning to eco-friendly Farm gear to
reduce their environmental footprint
while maintaining high yields but what
are the best tools for the job stay with
us as we highlight the top sustainable
farming Solutions that are making a real
difference for modern Farmers around the
world solar powered equipment for
sustainable farming solar powered
equipment is one of the most effective
ways to transition to sustainable
farming by harnessing renewable energy
from the Sun farmers can power
everything from irrigation systems to
Electric tractors without relying on
fossil fuels for example solar powerered
water pumps pull water from Wells or
nearby water sources to irrigate Fields
reducing the need for diesel power pumps
electric tractors powered by solar
panels can perform heavyduty tasks like
plowing and planting with zero emissions
lowering the Farm's carbon footprint
solar energy is not only eco-friendly
but also coste effective especially in
areas with plenty of sunlight over time
farmers can significantly reduce their
fuel and energy costs while maintaining
High productivity solar panels are
durable and require minimal maintenance
making them a smart long-term investment
for Farms of all sizes as more Farmers
adopt solar technology the industry is
moving toward a more sustainable and
eco-friendly future drip irrigation
systems for water conservation water is
one of the most precious resources in
agriculture and drip irrigation systems
are an Innovative way to use it more
efficiently unlike traditional sprinkler
systems which often lead to Water waste
due to evaporation or runoff drip
irrigation delivers water directly to
the plant's roots minimiz ing loss and
maximizing Effectiveness this method can
reduce water usage by up to 60% making
it ideal for areas facing water scarcity
additionally drip irrigation systems can
be automated using sensors to monitor
soil moisture levels in real time these
systems can automatically adjust
watering schedules based on current soil
conditions ensuring crops receive the
optimal amount of water without
overwatering by conserving water and
delivering it precisely where it's
needed
drip irrigation helps promote healthier
plants reduces Water waste and supports
more sustainable farming practices
organic fertilizers and soil Health
maintaining healthy soil is crucial for
long-term Farm productivity and using
organic fertilizers is one of the best
ways to enhance soil Health sustainably
organic fertilizers such as compost
manure and cover crops provide essential
nutrients to the soil while avoiding the
harmful chemicals found in synthetic
fertilizers
these natural fertilizers improve soil
structure increase its ability to retain
water and encourage the growth of
beneficial
microorganisms this not only helps
plants grow stronger but also reduces
the risk of nutrient runoff into nearby
water sources protecting
ecosystems by using organic fertilizers
farmers can build richer more fertile
soil over time leading to higher yields
without depleting the land as a result
organic fertilization is a key part of
sustainable farming Solutions supporting
both environmental health and long-term
Farm
productivity Precision farming
technology for sustainable resource use
Precision farming technology is
transforming the way resources are used
in agriculture making farming more
efficient and environmentally friendly
with GPS guided tractors and drones
equipped with sensors farmers can
monitor and manage their fields with
Incredible accuracy for example GPS
enabled tractors can plant seeds and
apply fertilizers precisely where
they're needed reducing overlap and
minimizing waste similarly drones can
survey large Fields Gathering real-time
data on crop Health water levels and
pest problems this data allows Farmers
to make informed data-driven decisions
about where and how to apply resources
like water fertilizers and pesticides by
using resources only where they are
necessary Precision farming technology
helps reduce environmental impact lower
costs and improve yields it's a perfect
example of how modern technology is
making farming more sustainable and
efficient now that we've explored the
top eco-friendly Farm gear we'd love to
hear from you what sustainable farming
tools have you already adopted on your
farm are you planning to switch to solar
powered equipment or drip irrigation let
us know in the comments below we'd love
to hear your thoughts and experiences on
sustainable farming Solutions thanks for
watching if you're interested in more
sustainable farming tips don't miss our
next video on how to implement Renewable
Energy Solutions on your farm be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
so you never miss an update from
Advanced Agri gears